apple is currently working on a brand
new wearable smart ring product that'll
bring on a bunch of new and great
features including sleep tracking that
doesn't rely on wearing an uncomfortable
Apple watch in bed as well as a week's
worth of battery life and I have a
feeling this new smart ring just might
put Aura ring out of business now if you
don't believe me I'm gonna prove it in
this video by showing you dozens of
Apple patents that prove they're
actively working on this new ring
product and let me tell you it's going
to be better than anything Aura could
ever make but before we get into those
patents I want to give you guys my
experience with this smart ring from
Rincon that I've been using for over a
month straight this thing has been
amazing because it tracks my sleep
activity and stress levels with great
accuracy especially all of my sleep
stages at night like deep sleep which I
love looking at however there are four
problems with it number one is that it
doesn't connect with my iPhone and
Health Data like apple does so it
doesn't close my rings number two is
that it feels pretty cheap despite
costing 279 dollars with visible
scratches on the Finish after just one
month number three is that sometimes it
spins without me noticing so the sensors
aren't properly aligned and they stop
tracking completely and number four is
that I have no idea who has access to my
precious Private health data now apple
is going to solve all of those issues
and more creating a high quality ring
with better materials allowing them to
even offer real gold Coatings at a
higher price to make more profit they'll
also make sure that my data is fully
encrypted like the Apple watch already
does and by the way this ring will also
be used as an accessory to device to
your Apple watch for things like sleep
tracking and much more I personally
think tons of people are going to buy
them because they're going to come in at
a lower price than the Apple watch does
and yes I believe it'll fully connect
with your Apple devices and close all of
your rings including being able to
interact with your other Apple devices
as well as possibly even including a
digital display and more Apple literally
has the perfect opportunity to enter the
smart ring Market which is growing
rapidly and basically get every iPhone
user interested in wearing one to take
advantage of all other features like
actively tracking blood oxygen levels
stress levels sleep and much more and
now let's go ahead and get into the
patins but first I want to show you guys
this from our sponsor Apollo it's a
wearable unlike any other because it
actively improves your health by
strengthening your nervous system though
by sending soothing and gentle waves of
vibrations called Apollo Vibes would you
like music you can feel reducing stress
and helping you relax during the day and
get more restful sleep at night you can
wear it with a band on either your wrist
or your leg and even on your chest or
your hip by using the clip and then you
can choose from a wide variety of Vibes
including a power nap that'll help you
soothe into your nap and then wake you
up on time it was created by
neuroscientists and Physicians and
tested in real world trials leading to
huge benefits like an increase of up to
19 more deep sleep on average so order
your Apollo wearable today using the
link below to start improving your HRV
your sleep your stress levels and much
more and now let's get into those apple
patterns starting with this one that
basically shows a hint at Apple's new
smart ring that they are going to start
making some time in the near future but
first the most important thing to
realize is that Apple almost always
shrouds the true intended beating for
their patents behind something else
without revealing what it's actually
meant for for example Apple once filed
this patent right here showing off a
virtual keyboard and multi-touch surface
using a camera to watch your hands
specifically if you go down you can see
that it was meant to be used with a
Macbook or iMac and their cameras
however we now know that the true
intended purpose for this patent was
actually for the brand new virtual
keyboard while using Apple's Vision Pro
headset they also applied for this
patent in 2022 for virtual group
FaceTime basically showing off a wall
mounted TV with cameras All Around The
Edge to capture your facial expressions
and eye gaze but once again again it
turned out to be that this patent was
meant for the Vision Pro headset with
interior mounted cameras to make group
FaceTime work with a virtual Avatar of
yourself so with that in mind let's jump
into the Apple smart ring patents
starting with this one apple invents a
smart ring that could sense a user's
health conditions such as heart rate
blood oxygen blood pressure and more now
right now my Rincon smart ring does the
blood oxygen very very well and
accurately it does heart rate but it
doesn't do blood pressure so I wonder
how apple is going to take care of that
but here it is Apple's patent for a
smart ring with basically a bunch of
images showing how you're going to be
using your wearable ring device while
using your iPhone with a bunch of
different sensors and then moving on we
have a patent that's actually shrouded
as something else you can see that Apple
invented a smart metal and fabric health
and Communications band for the Apple
watch and a future mixed reality headset
however I think this is literally just
their smart ring with a bunch of
built-in sensors because there's no
Apple watch here it's literally just a
ring with tons and tons of different
sensors which if you've looked on the
inside of one of the aura or Rincon
smart Rings there's a whole lineup of
sensors on the inside so I believe that
is what this is because even though they
say it's fabric material you can see
they have one point that says wherein
the housing is a metal housing basically
a smart ring moving on we have this
pattern right here that shows a new
smart ring device from Apple that can
control a bunch of different devices
including MacBooks iPhones Apple TV air
pods and head mounted displays which
sounds very interesting however you
could see that there's actually a scroll
wheel with two different Rings there's
an inner ring and an outer ring so the
outer ring will actually be able to move
around and scroll which probably shows
that you can adjust different things
within your UI of other devices like
your volume by spinning it around here's
another pattern right here showing the
same thing with an electronic Jewel
system and a rotating outer band and
stationary inner band with contact pads
band mechanism everything built in and
here you can see it's showing it
rotating just like that which could
probably adjust different devices is
just look at all of these patent images
now this pattern right here is going to
be the one that will solve the issue of
rings rotating around and losing contact
with the sensors because only the
outside will move so if you're in bed
moving around the inside will stay
stationary so no issues with that at all
and that's the most annoying thing with
this ring but now getting even weirder
we have a patent from Apple showing off
a smart ring that's meant to be a
controller for a mixed reality headset
which doesn't really make sense because
right now Apple has already revealed The
Vision Pro and we know that you don't
need any controllers no iPhones no rings
nothing you just use your hands so why
is this being related to the mixed
reality headset well it could be
shrouded as an excuse to get these smart
ring patents out the door and once again
right here we have another patent of a
smart ring connecting and controlling a
VR headset so what if in the future
there's going to be a better VR headset
that's going to work with these rings
for some type of input control even
though Apple doesn't need it I'm not
exactly sure here you can see that you
could actually snap your fingers and it
can detect that snap so for example you
could be doing some sort of gestures
with the ring and it can control
different devices and we see the same
thing here look at all these gestures
that can be detected by the smart ring
even wearing multiple of them and here
you can see there's different electrodes
different inputs all right here
including tapping on the ring itself for
touch input we see the same thing in
this pattern showing a ring being on
your device and an apple head mounted
device basically having tracking of your
hand with that ring maybe it works
better because of the Ring I'm not sure
showing all these different locations
that you can wear it there's even this
pattern that shows that the smart ring
will be able to detect sub Micron
movements with really really good sensor
detection which I don't know what that
can be used for but Apple can definitely
use it for some sort of Health tracking
and here we have another smart ring
pattern showing two rings being worn on
the hand with a bunch of SMI sensors
probably for more gestures or something
else like that and then this is perhaps
the most interesting one out of all we
have these mini flexible Edge displays
with repurposing active virtual buttons
that's shown on the side of the iPhone
however I believe that Apple would
rather take this flexible display and
stick it on the smart ring itself to
basically see new notifications or
whatever else popping up and with all
the touch sensitivity you can even
control it using your finger and then
here is a really weird patent showing a
bed in a new Apple sleep tracking device
to to measure all of your sleep stages
well I believe that this in bed device
is actually not something you put into
your bed but something you wear on your
ring you're going to be wearing your
ring with five to seven day battery life
and it's going to basically send the
information to your iPhone tracking all
of your different sleep stages but
basically with all of that said I think
we have enough evidence that apple is
working on a smart ring and by far the
most practical application for all these
patents is to literally just create an
aura ring competitor because if anyone's
gonna buy a smart ring it's going to be
from the company Apple's gonna do a
killer job making it thinner than the
rest of the competition with better
battery life better privacy data
security and encryption and better
materials apple is gonna sell tons of
these things and in terms of the pricing
I think they could price it probably
between three to 400 dollars maybe even
more if you want like a real gold
material finish on it but they're gonna
sell like hot cakes and to me I love the
sleep tracking because my Apple watch I
plug it in to charge at night I don't
want to be rolling around in bed with my
Apple watch it's just so annoying so
sleep tracking right now is kind of
crappy with Apple devices but an apple
smart ring would fix that for good and
they could even take it a step further
with a little stress level detection and
monitoring and then integrating that
with a new Mental Health Report that it
does for you showing off when you're
stressful or when you need to de-stress
Apple can Implement all those software
features with a smart ring so I think
that's what they're gonna do now I don't
know when it's gonna come out but they
are working on it for sure so hopefully
you enjoy this video let me know your
comments down in the comment section
below definitely watch one of those two
videos right there thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
foreign